[Musik]
und dann ist die erste aufgabe erst mal
überhaupt strom da rein zu kriegen weil
so viele leute ich habe jetzt den
fernseher geholt
du hast die lichterkette gebe mir noch
machen ok dann klaus jetz mal bei uns in
tannenbaum
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video und damit auch
einen wunderschönen guten morgen aus dem
garten leute endlich geschafft bevor er
das endresultat ist gleich sehen könnt
abonniert auf jeden fall den kanal wird
mich mega freuen
fast eine million leute ich hab's ja
gestern schon angekündigt heute steht
das video an indem wir diesen
wunderschönen autor iglu bei dem ich
ganz ehrlich sagen muss dessen sinn ich
noch nicht ganz verstanden habe also ich
habe mir wirklich vorgestellt das das
dingen stehen bleibt es einmal
aufgeblasen hat das ist ja nicht so ich
meine wenn man sich das jetzt hier mal
anschaut liegt ja wieder auf dem boden
also das bleibt dann vielleicht drei
minuten so stehen und dann ist das ding
auch wieder komplett runter gegangen das
ist natürlich ein bisschen schade und
lässt sich diesen produktfotos auch gar
nichts unternehmen das ist wirklich ein
ding ist was durchgehend irgendwie luft
benötigt weil ich meinen wo ist dann der
zweck dahinter wofür soll man das
benutzen wenn es immer wieder
zusammenfällt wenn ein neuer gast
reinkommt so hack und dann eben doch
diese pumpen
also ich weiß ich habe euch ja trotzdem
talent vorgeschlagen dass ich da mal
drin über nacht oder so vorher müssen
wir das natürlich einrichten und das
machen wir heute
wir fahren jetzt erst mal ein möbelhaus
dann fahren wir noch in ein anderes
möbelhaus und zwar habe ich euch ja
gestern im video auch gesagt dass sie
auf jeden fall vorschlägen in die
kommentare schreiben soll was da alles
rein soll ich habe mir ein paar
vorschläge ausgeprägt ich würde sagen
ich verrate das war noch nicht damit ihr
alles schön dran bleibt und wir sagen
let's go ich hoffe dass zeit
funktioniert überhaupt noch so
okay okay das hat sich schon mal gut an
es funktioniert noch und es hat heute
nacht nämlich auch echt stark geregnet
wenn ich mal gespannt wie das nächste
nacht wird wenn ich da drin schlafen
also leute letzte angekommen im auto
mich nehmen heute das auto von meinen
eltern wo wir hinten halt ziemlich
gestochen haben weil ich habe angst dass
die sachen die ich benötige bei mir
nicht reinpassen
das wäre ein bisschen blöd ich auch das
passt nicht allein von daher passt das
ganz gut dass das auto gerade hier ist
und auf geht's erst mal zu ich weiß ja
wie das kennt wahrscheinlich schon
dänisches bettenlager da hab ich nämlich
so ein angebot gefunden und ich hoffe
die haben noch das was ich benötige
also bis gleich okay leute da oben kann
man es ja sehen also ich weiß gerade
schon drin das ding ist die haben das
nicht was ich suche ich kann solche
eigentlich auch mal sagen und zwar suche
ich einen sitzsack also den meisten
sitzen habe ich mir richtig gut
vorgestellt da noch ein paar kisten
gärten zwar ganz coole kisten aber da
wusste ich jetzt nicht brauche ich
überhaupt kissen weil ich habe ja auch
genug essen zu hause
dann wollte ich jetzt nicht unnatürlich
30 euro für irgendwelche kissen ausgeben
aber ich gebe natürlich nicht auf wir
fahren jetzt zum nächsten möbelhaus ist
ein bisschen größer und ich denke mal
die haben da ein sitzsack wenn nicht
gibt es ärger so leute ich bin jetzt
hier in einem möbelhaus gelandet ist
gratis stühle gefunden ich brauche so
ein gaming stuhl
aber ich suche eigentlich ein sitz sagt
ich glaube aber hier gibt es auch keinen
halt ja es kann doch nicht sein das ist
ein riesending hier gibt es keine sagt
also ich habe zwar noch nicht alles
gesehen aber das sieht mir aus wie so
eine sitzecke
es gibt ja das wird auch gehen aber für
draußen 290 euro na ja so ein schrank
hier werden natürlich auch nicht
schlecht
hey leute das gibt es nicht mehr ich
weiß gerade hier kann ich einmal kurz
werbung machen also wenn da mal ein
placement partner sucht bei poco und die
nette mitarbeiterin hat gesagt die
hatten war sitzsäcke die sind allerdings
alle vor weihnachten weg gegangen
das problem ist das ist hier das einzige
möbelhaus was ein bisschen größer ist
ich hab kein kann wo ich jetzt meine
chance sitzer herkriegen soll ich war
gerade unseren billigladen da habe ich
jetzt wenigstens schon mal zwei kissen
gekauft damit ich irgendwas hat also für
das gewissen eigentlich nur von jetzt
bin ich gerade überlegen was ich machen
leute mittlerweile wieder draußen
ich muss jetzt erst mal dass er noch mal
neu befestigen weil die sind pendelte
gestern hatte die waren nicht stark
genug also muss ich mit dem hammer da
irgendwas im boden hauen damit dass auch
drin bleibt und diese seiten hat nicht
wieder so komisch hochgehen ich denke
wenn hin
später dann so ein sack drinliegt den
ich jetzt übrigens von einem kollegen
von mir bekommen habe also ich würde
gleich ab habe ich sogar noch geld
gespart da ein solches wenig mehr
wackeln aber man kann ja nie wissen
[Musik]
okay leute befestigt müsse es jetzt sein
jetzt schmeißt euch dem strohmann und
dann ist die erste aufgabe erst mal
überhaupt strom da rein zu kriegen weil
das habe ich mich auch noch nicht
erzählt ich möchte auf jeden fall noch
einen fernseher einbauen und eine
playstation und natürlich licht das wir
auch nicht schlecht oder halt eine lampe
die funktioniert mit stroh bereich aber
noch eine andere idee für so eine
deckenlampe ich weiß nicht ob mir die
kennt die sind von der marke fette beute
haben wir auch einige hier die kann man
sodann also die funktionieren mit akku
und sehen auch noch ziemlich stylish aus
die wollte ich so unter die decke hängen
oder noch ein paar sachen aber wir
fangen jetzt erst mal an und dafür muss
das ding wieder stehen es hat eine nacht
übrigens aufgeregt mit also ein bisschen
wasser ist drauf ich hoffe das läuft
dann jetzt gleich rund wird schon
klappen
ok günstigen steht jetzt wieder wird auf
video
neu ist auch dabei helfen wir jetzt ein
bisschen korrekte dass du gekommen
ich kann nicht mal kurz zeigen was ich
meine und zwar dass so eine kraft dass
diese haken hier wieder rausgezogen
werden
der boden ist dafür vielleicht auch ein
bisschen zu weich willst du auf geregnet
hat wir brauchen eigentlich ein längeres
kabel geh mal rein und noch mal schnell
die tür dazu
ja wieder zu genau ja da geht viel lob
da gäbe es viel luft raus das ist halt
ein bisschen dumm auch viele leute wir
sind jetzt hier drin
ihr habt ja gestern im video schon
gesehen wie das hier aussieht falls das
video bester nicht gesehen hat all das
ist auf jeden fall erstmal an auf jeden
fall habe ich jetzt gedacht aber wir
haben jetzt gerade da schon die chance
das ist ja so diese eingangsbereich das
kann ruhig dreckig werden weißt du ja
und dann kommen wir jetzt vielleicht
sowie das wackelt ich will ganz oben so
eine lampe ich würde eine lampe
befestigt dann kommt dieser sitzflächen
und hier kommt dann der fernseher hin
und die playstation und ich hoffe das
hält alles weil es ist echt eine
wacklige angelegenheit gesprochen habe
ich auf jeden fall schon mal okay dann
würde ich sagen auf den sitzen muss nur
noch ein bisschen warten
er kommt als letztes mal nico kommt das
um 17 uhr von der arbeit wieder und dann
wurde ich jetzt vielleicht erstmal den
fernseher
die playstation dann habe ich noch
kissen gekauft und dann die lichter und
das brauchen wir dann erst mal rein
willst du hier drin bleiben oder wird es
wieder rausgehen dieser ist übrigens
kalt der sonst so dass meine schuhe
zählt hatten sich hier noch krank
okay leute hier wird es den fernseher
geholt wir haben jetzt teppiche sonne
sitzt lounge kissen und strom und auch
die lampen dass muss jetzt aber erstmal
alles da rein
dann kommen auch die playstation habe
ich vergessen genau hierhin hat schon
mit internen durch einmal geboren
damit wir die gleich direkt eintragen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wer sich das mal auf dann gehst du das
andere reiht
okay leute die ersten sachen sind jetzt
drin dass wir mal anstrengend jetzt
kommt noch licht und playstation und das
ding ist der boden ist halt so uneben
das heißt wir müssen aufpassen dass der
fenster nicht umfällt also es kann
schnell passieren wir sehen uns gleich
wieder
wenn wir weiter sind wollen wir die noch
aufhängen diese buchstaben wir hatten
erwartet im rhein erst mal bis zur engen
okay leute ich stehe jetzt gerade hier
im vordach das ja die ganze welt immer
wieder zusammen sagt wir sollen also das
ist echt das nervigste jetzt kommen noch
die playstation was du vielleicht ist
einfach nur playstation 3 naja egal
besser als gar nichts okay wir filmen
100 der kleinen kammer jetzt das andere
ist uns viel zu umständlich war mir
anfang mit der lampe und entdecke ich
bin so gespannt was die zuhälter ist
können wir das wackelt ich weiß nicht so
ganz vertraulich der sache noch nicht
leute ich weiß es gibt besseres
klebeband dafür aber wir hatten uns
jetzt leider nicht dann haben es jetzt
erstmal so versucht muss halt dann
kommen jetzt noch die bauern die lampen
also die andere lampe und dann sind wir
schon mal ziemlich weit das ding ist
diese punkte die ich einfach so laut ich
habe wirklich vor so alle nach hinten
aber meint man kann noch gar nicht oder
da muss ich mir erst mal zur ordnung
kümmern und dann haben wir auch die
ganze zeit wirkt schon da das heißt
danach ist man ja krank deswegen will
ich etwas so wohl schon mal leiser auf
jeden fall warte macht auch die lampe
und alles was ich mir noch
heute die technischen fürchtet runter
das obere licht auch könig der sich
schlecht gesteht ihr eure firma jetzt
mich jetzt schon ziemlich alter also
leute wir sind schon mal halbwegs weit
also diese lounges jetzt aufgebaut und
jennifer jetzt wenn auch die pumpe aus
ja weil ok und hier ist noch der atem
als es müsste eigentlich über wlan
verbunden seien ja funktioniert doch du
bist angemeldet okay ich mache jetzt
noch mal ein paar aufnahmen mit der sony
kamera oder ich mach das eventuell
gleich wenn es dunkel wird weil ich
glaube ich das richtig nice aus als
wären jetzt auf jeden fall schon mal die
wichtigsten sachen hier drin fernseher
playstation sofa oder halbwegs sofa dann
auch ihren teppich kissen falls euch
noch irgendwas einfällt kommentiert das
auf jeden fall hier mal und wir sehen
uns dann gleich wenn es dunkel ist du
hast gesagt lichterkette kann man noch
machen
okay dann sag ich jetzt mal was aus dem
tannenbaum leute nur hatte die heftige
idee dass wir hier noch so bisschen
accessoires dran machen ein bisschen
dekoration entschuldigung und zwar steht
jetzt gleich home.de ja und dann wenn
dann noch eine lichterkette drin ist und
ist einleuchtend ist an dunkel ist
irgendwas wird das heftigste iglu du
bist so einen künstler will werbung
machen für den integra nur los mit drei
f oder hast du nicht mehr so
den leuten was auf
jamann
eine ungewohnt eine hohe drin
war
geile
wenn es dunkel ist wie das so heftig
aussehen leute nur ein problem die lampe
ist runtergefallen scheiße nach erst
jetzt kaputt weil die alters schon
zweieinhalb meter fallhöhe leute werden
die lampen jetzt da hingegangen vorne in
eingangsbereichen zwar gespannt ob das
feld
[Musik]
so leute was geht ja wir haben jetzt
schon ein bisschen später wieder auf
also ist halt echt lange gedauert das
aufbauen gestern hatte ich mal halb so
langen gedacht nicht mal ein viertel von
dem was wir heute gebraucht haben also
die ganzen sachen dar eintragen dann
immer wieder hier vorne die luft raus
luft rein
also es war echt anstrengend muss ich
sagen ich bin jetzt mit dem endresultat
aber auf jeden fall ziemlich zufrieden
auch mit den ganzen lichterketten und so
sieht echt nice aus ein problem gab es
und zwar diese richter könnte die jetzt
gerade im iglu ist die ist irgendwie
halb schrott also das funktioniert nur
jede zweite
das ist ein bisschen schade sonst können
sie noch krasser aussehen und ich glaube
das ist auch immer ein bisschen schwer
auf der kamera rüberzubringen
weil die halt nicht jedes licht so
aufnehmen kann wie das menschliche auge
am meisten feiere ich eigentlich dass
hier wieder hoch dankeschön also das
sieht echt heftig aus aber ich habe
gerade schon eine menge aufnahmen
gemacht ich glaube da kann man das ganz
gut erkennen wie es jetzt halt wirklich
aussieht er hat ja schon gehört und ich
habe es euch auch ihnen versprochen dass
ich auf jeden fall meine nachbarin über
nacht werde
das habe ich jetzt eigentlich geplant
wir heute nacht weil ich morgen wieder
nach köln fahren
deswegen habe ich auch schon die mütze
auf also das video gibt es dann
übermorgen am donnerstag wahrscheinlich
ich habe mir nämlich gedacht dass
mittwoch jetzt immer ruhetag ist also
mittwochs gibt es kein video von mir
preis ja schade aber das ist uns auf
dauer einfach ein bisschen zu
anstrengend für mich weil ich ja auch
noch ein paar andere sachen versuche zu
machen und ja leute abonniert auf jeden
fall den kanal es fehle nicht nur viele
bis eine million einfach nur einmal kurz
klicken instagram heißt alex wie ich
hoffe dass wir dort euch gefallen ich
habe mir echt mühe gegeben und wir sehen
uns dann halt am donnerstag wieder um 19
uhr gibt's neues video
haut rein
[Musik]